ولكن نحن نتواجد الان في هذه المنطقه
والحديقه الكبيره جدا لننقل الاثار
الجانبيه لهذا الزلزال وهي اثار كبيره جدا
وعصفت بالكثير من الاسر حيث في هذه
الحديقه الكبيره جدا
والمتراميه الاطراف تتواجد عدد كبير جدا
من
الخيم على يمينه ويسار الحديقه وهذا
التوقيت تحديدا هو توقيت الغذاء الذي يتم
تقديمه من قبل هذه
الحافله الكبيره التي تم وضعها من قبل
السلطات التركيه
طابور طويل خالد من هذه
من هؤلاء الاشخاص الذين ينتظرون الحصول
على وجبه الغداء في هذه اللحظات وهم
يتواجدون في خيم متفرقه يعني تواجدت في
احد الخيم قبل قليل وكان يقول لي باحد
الساكنين في هذه الخيام ب في الليل برد
قارس جدا لا يستطيعون
مجابهه هذا البرد او حتى توازيا معه عبر
او يعني ان يكون هنالك وسائل تدفئه ليست
لديهم هم يطالبون بهذا الشيء نظرا للكم او
درجات الحراره المتدنيه وايضا العدد
الكبير جدا من المتواجدين
متواجدون في هذه الحديقه تحدث عن نازحون
اتراك وايضا سوريين دمرت منازلهم او البعض
الاخر منزله لم يدمر ولكن ولم ينهدم ولكن
ينتظر ان تقوم السلطات التركيه بعمليه فحص
لهذا المنزل لحين عودته
اليه وان يطمئن بان المنزل امن في الايام
القادمه فربما حتى تطول هذا يطول هذا
الموضوع الى الاسابيع القادمه